la vita è un viaggio imprevedibile ad
ogni svolta della strada Sono stata
invasa dal rumore di migliaia di domande
e dal silenzio di nessuna risposta
lo so bene che cosa vuol dire sentirsi
spaesati completamente persi in noi
stessi in balia di paure ed angosce in
balia di quei venti contrari che ci
portano a credere di non essere
abbastanza di non valere di abbandonare
la strada maestra perché è complessa per
imboccarne una più asfaltata più diritta
più semplicemente percorribile
Ma la vita è così è una gran bastarda e
lo dico con segno di causa
ma non possiamo e lo dico a me tanto
quanto a voi non possiamo piegarci suoi
voleri con inerzia Ma dobbiamo
continuare a lottare a combattere ad
andare avanti nonostante gli ostacoli
nonostante le cadute Io sono Ilaria
parlanti una scrittrice sceneggiatrice
Toscana come sentirete sicuramente dal
mio accento ma anche attrice ed
attivista e sono qui per condurvi per
mano nel viaggio più incredibile che
potete fare
quello di rinascere dalle proprie ceneri
come Fenici novelle
era il 2020 il nostro mondo stava
impazzendo cadendo in Prandelli ai piedi
di una pandemia le porte dei locali
degli uffici delle nostre case venivano
tutti chiusi con suoni Sordi ed io come
penso anche molti di voi mi ritrovavo
immersa nelle quattro pareti di camera
mia e pensavo
è lì che è cominciata la mia
introspezione quando la voce che sentivo
nella testa quella voce che poi è
diventata la coscienza di me stessa
quella voce fuori campo del film della
mia vita interiore Ebbene quella voce mi
diceva di lasciare la presa di
abbandonare l'ascia di guerra contro me
stessa ma anche che mi odiavo e odiavo
il mio corpo e lo avrai sempre fatto
fino alla notte dei tempi
non mi accettavo Anzi
provavo proprio disgusto per la persona
che ero diventata sempre timida sempre
succube degli eventi del mondo Sempre
con qualcosa da dire sulla punta della
lingua ma mai con vero coraggio per
preferirlo ad alta voce
e bene io mi odiavo per la storia che ho
alle spalle e
odiavo le cicatrici lunghe tutta una
schiera posso dire lunghe tutta una vita
mi odiavo soprattutto per quelle
etichetta
quella del disabile che mi ha
accompagnato per tutta la vita
e che in qualche modo mai mi affrancherò
di far parte di una minoranza che porta
terrore e pietismo in chi non è toccato
Ebbene sì io ho una storia da raccontare
e oggi la voglio raccontare proprio a
voi sono nata 25 anni fa con la sindrome
di Jacques Levine una malattia recessiva
assai rara che comporta la malformazione
delle ossa della gabbia toracica della
colonna vertebrale e degli organi
interni come cuore e polmoni la prognosi
data il giorno della mia nascita ai miei
genitori è stata morte certa per
elisione e soffocamento dei polmoni E
dell'esofago allora i miei genitori mi
accompagnarono a casa per lasciarmi
morire ma ciò non accade nei tre giorni
successivi al mio rientro come
prospettato dai medici e nemmeno dopo
sei mesi
Allora i miei genitori iniziarono a
peregrinare per tutti gli ospedali
d'Italia e tutti arrivavano alla
medesima conclusione il mio caso non era
compatibile con la vita
soltanto all'estero a Parigi per la
precisione un chirurgo sentì della mia
problematica e si decise a farsi avanti
proponendo un percorso sperimentale
chirurgico nella capitale francese il
suo è stato il tentativo che mi ha
salvato la vita
dopo 24 operazioni alla colonna
vertebrale
protesi in acciaio lunghe tutta una
schiena un infinito numero di corsetti
gessati e di plastica Io sono viva certo
la qualità della vita non è eccelsa
soffro di dolore cronico un cuore
tachicardico una lesione midollare alla
gamba destra o una Severa compromissione
della capacità Vitale respiratoria ma
sono qui e lo posso raccontare
è stato proprio qualche giorno dopo la
chiusura dell'8 quella che conosciamo
bene la chiusura dell'8 marzo 2020 che
il dolore cronico mi ha allettato
completamente per 7 mesi 7 lunghi mesi
trascorsi prigioniera nel mio letto
incapace di alzarmi anche per andare in
bagno o per i pasti Inutile dirvi che è
stato un inferno terreno dove i miei
pensieri hanno cominciato a
spiraleggiare come meta infestanti ed
uno ricorreva immancabilmente
la mia vita è rovinata
la spirale ha continuato invadendomi la
mente
gettandomi in ansia generalizzata
attacchi di panico disturbo post
traumatico da stress
depressione reattiva ma ne sono uscita
fuori lo devo dire non mi vergogno a
dirlo con la psicoterapia e gli
psicofarmaci che tutt'oggi assumo
regolarmente Ma come ho fatto davvero ad
uscirne
in due modi primo ho cercato un chirurgo
Che si decidesse a rischiare il tutto
per tutto e riportarmi in sala
operatoria
estirpandomi la causa fisica del dolore
cronico e due scrivendo
scrivere è la mia passione ma chiamarlo
passione sarebbe riduttivo scrivere è la
mia ragione di vita ed ha fatto parte
della mia terapia
in quei mesi di farmaci o tenebanti di
lacrime e di dolore io ho scritto il mio
primo romanzo ed ho ripercorsi in chiave
romanzata tutta la mia storia dalle
origini ai sentimenti più vicini che ho
incontrato nel tempo mi sono condotta
per mano e le intemperie di una malattia
di cui ho soltanto Oggi conosco il nome
che mi ha distrutto e vero l'infanzia e
l'adolescenza ma mi ha dato anche molto
di cui dialogare La forza della vita e
il dono della pazienza Io penso che nel
mondo
nel mondo labile e fugace di oggi le
cose belle quelle che ci portano
veramente Gioia abbiano bisogno di tempo
per svilupparsi come pianta annaffiate
con cura ed il mio tempo oggi è arrivato
faccio il mio coming out qui su questo
palco insieme a voi ed inizia ad urlare
al mondo questo modo io sono viva sono
qui ora e sì sono disabile
è stato grazie alla scrittura se ho
abbandonato l'odio per abbracciare
l'amore quella forma più pura che molte
volte diamo per scontata ma è che
necessità per una vita felice l'amor
proprio l'accettazione delle proprie
fragilità e delle proprie debolezze i
miei talloni di Achille sono diventati i
miei punti di forza le lacrime le ho
trasformate in sorrisi e anche le
cicatrici sono divenute Non segni di un
corpo deforme ma testimonianze di una
tenacia straordinaria
ho combattuto tutti i giorni contro
quella parte che di Messi vergognava si
vergognava della mia storia ma non l'ho
lasciata vincere alla fine
tutto quel soffrire Mi ha portato ad una
consapevolezza che non riuscivo nemmeno
ad esprimere a parole all'inizio ma che
sicuramente ho inserito nel romanzo
Ovviamente la mia protagonista ci arriva
a 40 anni Io fortunatamente Ci sono
arrivata a 25 ma non c'è un'età giusta
per cambiare la vita è fatta di bivi e
di decisioni e sta solo a noi condurre i
giochi
Certo A volte c'è lo zampino del caso ma
quello che conta davvero è il modo in
cui reagiamo agli eventi e voi Mi
potreste dire e se non ce la facessi se
mi dimostrassi un fallimento perché non
riesco a cambiare prospettiva Io vi
direi nessuno è un fallimento nessuno
finché sia la forza di tentare lo può
essere le cadute fanno parte del
percorso non importa Quante volte si
cade Ma quante riusciamo ad alzarci
Io ho preso la mia decisione un anno fa
non mi sarei più nascosta dal giudizio
degli altri mi sono guardata allo
specchio io ho deciso che sarei cambiata
alla fine l'ho trovato il chirurgo che
mi ha riportato in sala operatoria ci
sono entrata con una paura viscerale e
ne sono uscita senza più quel dolore
lancinante poi c'è stata tanta
fisioterapia per reimparare a camminare
in modo adeguato ma adesso ci siete voi
c'è il Tex ci siete voi che mi ascoltate
c'è questo mondo Allora vi chiedo però
di non prendermi come un esempio
infallibile da seguire perché comunque
sono umana e sono soggetta all'errore ma
due consigli ve li voglio lasciare
siate sempre voi stessi ed inseguite i
vostri pazzi sogni Perché la vita è
fatta per il sognatore ribelli
siate diversi ogni giorno è la vostra
vita affinché il cambiamento sia reale e
possa essere a te attuato
Mi raccomando
ricordatevi di essere anormali che non
lo omologazione ci stanno bene gli altri
insomma la scienza ci dice che
il DNA umano è fatto
diverso per ogni singola persona quindi
non esiste una uguale all'altra come Si
suole pensare
siate diversi non abbiate paura e se
siete un po' perfezionisti come lo sono
io colma di timidezze di paure vi dico
una frase che affermava il fisico
Stephen Hawking
l'universo Non ammette perfezione
pensate ma non troppo siate intrepidi ma
anche razionali
Perdonatemi delle colpe che portate come
proprie ma che magari non sono nemmeno
di vostro pugno
Amatevi io vi ho detto all'inizio che la
vita è un viaggio imprevedibile E allora
in questo viaggio imprevedibile che
chiamiamo vita ricordatevi di essere
felici Grazie
[Applauso]